very ambitious and and I love that you
know we're looking after people and
we're looking at their dreams and then
that's preserving to the companies we
look after what's the company dream
where does this company want to go to
and how do we achieve those dreams and
how do we become part of it really at
the end of the day we are people
business
um and and that gets me up in the
morning gets me going welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
I'm really excited to share with you
this episode with Loki whose entire
career has been devoted to serving
companies technical needs after earning
his master network engineering
qualification he became a technical
trainer for torque it and shortly after
this he was promoted to technical
manager Loki then joined tronic trade
technology Holdings and served as a
technical manager he then spent over a
decade at natureit starting as a senior
technical consultant he worked his way
up to head of support and was part of
the executive team following a
three-year stint at Dimension data is a
service improvement and enablement
manager and part of the GSC management
team who rejoined the nature team in
2017 to help grow the US business
phenomenal really really happy to have
you here talking about some things that
you truly are excited about and
passionate about and seem to have a
really fascinating career and journey
developing both in the technical sphere
and also the on a leadership level and
so I'm looking forward to sort of
unpacking this journey with you talking
about some of the fields that you're
that you're excited about security and
otherwise and will be a lot of fun
together and so I'd love to just start
off with a simple yet very complex
question you know what do you really
care about you know what what's
something that really
you know what's top of mind for you
that's that's that's a great question
for me top of mind is really three
things and it's in combination of
Technology people and process and
there's three things sort of create this
cohesion of of a totality for me I'm
very passionate about those things and
and yeah that that really gets me
excited in the morning and just want to
get going
and so what how does that you know what
what how does that come to play in your
day-to-day how do you perceive that
so into a day-to-day perspective
um where a managed service provider that
helps a lot of organization with those
three things so from a day-to-day
perspective security comes up these days
quite often a lot of companies are
seeing these days cyber security
breaches
um and they don't totally understand
what it is and how do I deal with it
um what's the laying fruit talking about
quickly and easily secure my business to
a certain level
um so from a day-to-day perspective I
deal a lot with seeing that and helping
companies understand how do I do the 80
20 from a security perspective how do I
become more compliant and really
utilizing technology the people that I
have and then the best business
processes behind that
so what what world are we living in
today why is this something that is
relevant to be top of mind for somebody
like yourself today
so I think since the pandemic uh the
world has changed a lot where everybody
used to be a lot more behind firewalls
in corporate networks
um people have now shifted in we've got
this hybrid world where some days in
office some days you're in office
um and it's created the world in a very
more
um open network which I have created a
lot of gaps within the ecosystem so it's
made it a lot easier to penetrate these
environments
um if you look at at just high level
stats we've seen a 300 increase in cyber
security breaches over the last couple
of years
um so it's very rough out there which is
unfortunate but we are also seeing that
they're targeting the SME Market a lot
more heavily
um and and it it's almost the wild west
out there unfortunately
and so the challenges that are presented
as a result so what what you know what
are the challenges as a result of the
current circumstance that we need to now
overcome
so I think some of the challenges is
some of the Business Leaders are a
little bit afraid of that security
because they don't understand it they
don't know where do I start so I think
the first thing is recognize that there
is a problem in the industry and then
what are those little steps that I can
start taking to educate myself a little
bit better get somebody that I can work
with to get a better view of that
landscape and then based on your
business outcomes and your business
objectives then start aligning what
security things you want to put in place
to to fortify and mitigate some of your
risks and again it's going to be very
different for each business depending on
your industry depending on what your
business will do you'll invest
differently in that cyber security but I
think the the shift has changed that
urge any of the big guards to begin to
browsers that need to think about
security it's not actually everybody and
you need to start building a roadmap in
certain levels of harm I'm going to
mature with time
um my maturity around security and my
governance
um perspective
and so the chef from large Enterprises
to smaller companies let's look at it
from sort of the smaller companies
perspective where does it meet them
right I mean where does it meet the
smaller companies mindset what
challenges does it does it possess to
them
I think from a practical perspective
most of the organizations out there are
either on Microsoft or Google and they
give you great resources already that
can give you guidance from a security
perspective so Microsoft's got something
called the secure school now most
Business Leaders don't know that there
is something like that but just going
and having a look at your secure score
or your partner or whatever you're
working with asking them can I send a
monthly basis my secure school where am
I and we'll actually show you how you're
doing compared to your peers in the
industry so you can see am I ahead of
the curve am I behind the curve and what
should I do to get in front of it um so
again there's great resources but what
we find is a lot of organizations don't
know that those resources even exist so
if you don't know what you don't know
it's really hard to progress and and
therefore Business Leaders need to take
this really serious and just start
educating them a little bit more around
what's going on in the security space
because
a simple example
if you look at your car when you park
your car in the parking lot you know
you're gonna arm the the car you're
gonna press the button the car's locked
and you know you have some sort of
security same with our businesses we
need to start having some of these
alarms in place and a lot of businesses
these days are just leading their their
companies wide open so it's starting
with that and then over time insuring it
and so the right way to go about this
from your perspective
so right where I would say first and
foremost is the Business Leaders to to
say you know we are going to take
security really
take the mindset from a security
perspective and say we're going to take
it serious you know it's not just
my data but it's my client's data and
how do I educate myself how do I get to
know where am I today and put a pig in
the ground to say what do we have in
place and if you don't know that get
somebody that you can work with either
you need to bring that resource
internally that's normally a little bit
harder for the smaller SME businesses
for the bigger businesses that's a
potential art the other artist is get a
consultant get a partner somebody that
understands the space and just say give
me assessment tell me where I am today
so you don't even have to do a full
engagement but just get a view of where
you're on based on that you can make an
educated business decision how much your
risk am I willing to take and what
should I do to to move to the next step
got it and so well how how is your sort
of day-to-day look like right now what
do you spend your time doing you know
your vice president a large company at
nature so what how what's your
day-to-day like so my day today is
really helping a lot of these businesses
understand the risks that they have so
we have managed service providing we
work with lots of
um different Industries and really
connecting with other leaders out there
and saying are you aware of these risks
you're very simple easy steps that you
can do to protect yourself we would do a
risk assessment for them and of that
we'll give our 80 20 years the lying
fruit have you got multi-factor
authentication as a simple example
configured I'm DF encryption enabled and
again depending on what the business is
doing it would dictate how far do we go
down the security stack and because
unfortunately the more secure you become
the less the return so for Bank they'll
have a lot more security and prices
governance in place versus somebody
that's in construction
but having said that if you're in
construction you still want security
because you might be dealing with
somebody and you're building a home for
them for instance if you get attacked or
fished and your account is breached
you'll plant you might not have a
financial problem but your client might
get then breached through a phishing
attack and they pay the money into their
own account and and now your client has
lost a lot of money and the hard looks
on your business is terrible so maybe
they didn't go after you as a business
but your customer might be very wealthy
on a high net worth individual and they
then get the breach and that really
doesn't bode well for your business and
your brand and your Equity within the
market and so it's not always just your
business you need to think about your
clients and you have high interest
clients because that's the people that
they're going to be off to
and if you're looking at Trends and
we're extrapolating on the sort of where
we're headed how do you see that you
know if we're looking at where we are
because it sounds like the discussions
that we're having now I'm I'm I and I'd
love to hear your opinion on on when
when did they really become relevant
sort of when did we really say okay now
this is when something that you know is
worthy of us having a you know a podcast
conversation about and and where are we
headed from here with them
I would say the last four years has
exponentially gotten worse and worse
um the pandemic really really kicked it
off and and made it a lot worse than
than before
um but for me what what was stating is
one out of three where we do these
assessments we find an active breach in
the environment
um so we're seeing also that these guys
that's doing the breaches are just lying
dormant and they'll be there in your
system for six months a year wow they
wait for that one million dollar deal
that's gonna go through and that's when
they attack so it's it's it's just rough
out there and it's it's very unfortunate
and basically these hackers today that's
their day job they've got 500 accounts
that they're just monitoring the whole
day they're getting all the data coming
into these systems they playing with AI
and making sure you know they're looking
for certain sentiments in communication
going in and out of your company and
once they see the right communication
going through the onion and you have the
breach
so again it's it's it's sad and what
we've seen as well is cyber security
Insurance becoming very strict so
there's so many breaches that the cyber
security insurance companies are now
saying well you've got insurance but you
said yeah two-factor authentication on
all your systems you said you had
encryption oh you didn't no you didn't
sorry your policy is invalid we're not
going to bet you out so again the the
layers of complexity as exponents
exponentially expanded
um so it's it's interesting world out
there
how do you how and I'm feeling from your
sentiment so you perhaps already know
the answer but
how do you perceive the preparedness in
comparison to the to the rising
challenges or the rising threats it's a
it's a big Challenge and and we see
a couple of different scenarios playing
out we get a lot that I'm too small I'm
even going to be breached and then two
months later they found us in a half and
a puff and say oh this is happen to me I
can't believe it please help
um we then see the other side of the
coin that they really start working on
that road map and and I would say that's
the most important thing if you can have
a roadmap we understand by trades are
limited but if you can start in saying
you know this month or the this court
till the next six months we're gonna do
multi-factor Authentication
next year we're going to do encryption
next year we're going to do a Sim
solution where we bringing all the dates
in and we're monitoring what's coming in
another environment and next we're going
to do EDR endpoint detect and response
type of thing and keep on building
um because the the net effect is your
security always need to be one better
than whoever is in your
sector because if you're a little bit
harder and it's terrible saying that but
if you're a little bit harder to reach
they're going to go for the easier guy
um and that's the thing you're just
gonna have to keep on reinvesting and
reinvesting because they get clever they
get better and so it's you have to keep
in front of this game and it's it's a
cost of operating a business
um it's it's the same instance that
you've got a alarm in your car and and
in some countries you'll have anti-high
Jack stuff in your car that tracks the
car and depending on the sector
dependent this is just a part of the
operating model and the part of cost of
running a business today
completely
so more tangible you know for young
entrepreneurs young organizations first
of all how early do you think
organizations should be you know or you
know different leaders and organizations
should be thinking about this and and
what are really the most actionable
things for them to do you know right you
know at that point of intervention that
you would describe so
I think from a core Foundation the
sooner you do things the right way and
as your business scales the hot the
easier it is to scale them because you
already have the right processes now
what some of the easy tangible stuff
make sure you're using a multi-factor
authentication on all your logins
doesn't matter where you go always have
a 2fa MFA
logging process
passwords use password phrases use
complexity not the same password for
everything and use the type of password
Vault where you keep all your passwords
secure and and have a variety each post
with a different one so again there's
this some of these small easy things and
if that is the process of the company it
just then embedded in part of the
culture and that's how you operate if
you relaxed about it and then all of a
sudden you're 20 people 30 people 50
people then to go back and re-engineer a
lot of those things become very hard and
the culture is already relaxed about it
I don't have to care about it
um and and so it really starts from
inception and really over that mindset
always on
yeah I think that's uh I I mean all
those steps sound you know definitely
necessary and I'm curious how how um how
would you describe the intervention
levels of the sort of the the executive
management of companies at different
stages in terms of not just being
proactive with the safeguarding of you
know vaults and secrets and the sort of
the password-like environment but how
proactive should the executive leaders
be in different growth stages in working
with perhaps even organizations that
could you know be of Aid beyond what you
know we could proactively do ourselves
so the biggest part in breaches is the
end user So to that answer people really
need to educate themselves and and they
are great systems and tools out there
that brings in user awareness so it's
not yet to be a cyber security
specialist and how to do it but you need
to know what's a phishing attack what am
I looking for it's gonna have the
display name it's going to look like the
CEO is asking me to buy 50 Apple gift
cards for some client go and have a look
deeper where is that thing coming from
is it really that email address or not
as a simple example so really in user of
awareness I feel is a big part that a
lot of companies are lacking and again
there's great tools that will give you a
full module and you can track all people
taking the training are they passing the
training and then even as far as it can
run simulation attacks within the
environment so it can do a phishing
attacking to the environment and it will
show you is then taking the bait and you
can go back and do more training and
again it's not to go back to those users
and and read you'll be hard on them but
it's to say we've got a problem here we
need to be more aware of it and work
with them on education path to make them
more aware of these things
so transitioning a little bit to to you
you know I asked you in the beginning
you know what do you care about my an
evolution of that is sort of why do you
do what you do
you know why why are you doing this you
know why are you so interested about
this and you know why is this such a big
part of your life
so it's a great question
um I've been in technology since the 80s
on now then looked at all uh but I had
my first computer as a kid otherwise the
ZX Spectrum I ran off type drives
um so for me big passion about
technology I love just tools and toys
and and all the gadgets um as you can
see my small little TV behind me
um I've got a little toy here that can
do all kinds of funky things for me on
the screen and bring up both kinds of
things so for me technology I'm very
passionate about technology and and love
that
um and then the other side for me is
people I love people
um I play professional ice hockey for
South Africa and it's a team sport it's
all about people and and within that
within people is that process part being
part of a team how do we get the best
out of the team so for me that's just
one really passionate about those things
and it's just close to my heart
and so how does the team experience
coming to play with your line of work
today
thing that team our team is we've got
something called the dreams program and
our course is supporting the dreams of
the doers so although we are technology
organization we're all about people in
their dreams and what are they trying to
achieve in life
um so for me I'm very ambitious and and
I love that you know looking after
people we're looking at their dreams and
then that's preserving to the companies
we look after what's the company dream
where does this company want to go to
and how do we achieve those dreams and
how do we become part of it because what
we found is if people are happy and
engaged it just pulls over and
everything if you're engaged in your own
life you're engaged in our clients
you're engaged in our business and and
it really at the end of the day we are
people business
um and and that gets me up in the
morning gets me going
I love it Loki I really want to thank
you for for the time and the energy and
the insights I mean it sounds like what
you're describing here is something that
you know it's um it's it's something
that we that you know it's that it's
very convenient to not think about until
you have to deal with it and then once
you deal with it you're you're kicking
yourself in the leg saying okay what
where was I right and it sounds like a
lot of these things that uh require some
active
um some activeness both from the
leadership perspective but also from an
educational perspective not just from
the not just from your employees but
also from the from the users and to
understand the complexities here and
this arms race and it and the challenges
that are presented and so I want to
thank you for coming here and sharing
with me your insights and your
observations and your excitement and
passion and I thank you very very much
thanks Michael it's been great being
part of the show and thanks for having
me thank you thank you very very much
thank you